good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is paint what you want over to
you Warren Buffett what brings you the
most satisfaction beyond family
well most criticize back she's just
taking Goodell but you're 86 I reckon if
you have to go look at this a little
never good so you you're in good health
oh yeah I mean I enjoy every day I enjoy
and what is it that you enjoy well I
enjoy running Berkshire I mean if you
get right down to the myosin psyche I
mean it's what I wanted yeah I know it's
it's you know it it's been my painting
for 50 some years I get to paint what I
want I don't have to I don't have to do
you know follow what Wall Street is
telling me to do in that quarter or
something like that so I own the brush I
own the canvas and the canvas is
unlimited and that's a it's a pretty
nice game and I get to do it every day
with people I like I don't have to I
don't have to associate with anyone that
causes my stomach to churn you know if I
were in politics I'd have to smile a lot
of people but I want to hit it so I go
to them it's really I've got a good deal
on but I'm hanging on to it this is
always a great reminder that you are in
control of your own brush you'll be the
artist you get the paint what you want
and you are in control of your brush
we're too often we blame other people
you might blame your boss if you have a
job that you're trying to get out of you
might blame your circumstances and as
soon as you start blaming somebody else
it makes you feel good about yourself
because it's not your fault anymore
right so it's somebody else's fault I
can feel better about myself but as soon
as you give away that responsibility as
soon as you give you a brush of somebody
else then you're never going to grow
it's hopeless you're never going to make
the painting that you want and so it
always starts with you picking up your
brush and owning your canvas
and that may not be a full-time thing
like there's realities of the world you
might have a family might have kids you
might have a spouse you might have big
debt there's lots of reasons you know
that are slowing your progress but you
can still pick up that brush every day
and paint something right you could
spend 30 to 60 minutes every single day
on your business and if you did that
you'll start to see major growth in your
business what ends up happening is the
the pressures of life and everything
else is happening start beating down on
you you haven't skilled using enough
time to focus on your business you don't
set enough boundaries around to say this
is secret time that I need to focus on
doing the things that I say I want to do
but if you have this big goal you have
to start matching your actions to the
goal you start you have to start taking
action on the thing that you say you
want to do you have to pick up your
brush and every day start painting and
so for those of you who haven't gotten
full time or aren't taking enough action
schedule in the time in your calendar
consistently so that it's happening so
you know Monday night at nine o'clock
and Tuesday nights at nine o'clock or
whatever the time is if it's best for
your schedule make sure it's being put
in there so you have time to paint the
other side of the entrepreneur's to
start to get bored the entrepreneurs who
have a business who've had some success
but then they've plateaued and they kind
of just staying here at the same level
not growing not get anything from it
anymore and a lot of these entrepreneurs
in common it's common to get bored of
your business it's common to then want
to quit your business or they or to look
for something else that you want to do
because this business isn't giving you
the satisfaction and enjoy anymore and a
big reason for that is because you
dropped a brush like you stopped
creating something new you let the
success that you've had in the past the
change that prevent you from moving
forward so talking to a youtuber
recently who's going through this and he
has this special channel he's trying to
build it up but he's had kind of flat
growth and he feels like he's making the
same videos over and over and over again
and there's no variety in the content
anymore you not sure what to do about it
should he sell his channel should he
focus on a different business shitty
startup other joint ventures sure to get
into podcasting she did just go and do
something else and the reason why he's
frustrated and bored is because he lost
the creativity he's not doing new things
anymore right he dropped his brush used
to pick it back up and just start to
paint again
do something different I love the series
on my channel
I love making every new series I'm
constantly inviting new series in if I
don't like a series anymore I'll drop it
even if it's really popular if I'm not
enjoying it I'm going to drop because I
don't want to come here and talk to you
guys on a consistent basis something I'm
not passionate about and so we're
constantly trying new things new series
new ideas I'm constantly painting my
channel is not the same yes we're making
YouTube videos but it's not the same as
I was a year ago and it's not going to
look the same as it will in another year
from now in two years and five years and
ten years and so the key is to be
constantly evolving as an entrepreneur
constantly picking up the brush
constantly painting new things and if
you go too long as a creative
entrepreneur without painting without
expressing without putting yourself into
the business and you get stuck in a
day-to-day grind of running the
operations you will get bored you will
crash you will want to shut down you
will want to look at something else you
will want to sell the business you will
want to move on and so if that's you I'd
strongly encourage you to look at how do
I consistently find new ways to pick up
the brush and keep painting up in budget
so the question today today is I'm
curious how often are you creating new
things for your business how often are
you expressing your creativity into your
company how consistent is that for you
is it failing is it once a week is that
once a month is it once a quarter I love
to hear from you leave it down in the
comments below also for people who leave
comments within the first few hours of
this video going live you have a chance
to win one or two really prizes I also
want to give a quick shout out to Marcus
Campbell Marcus thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book gear one
word and making a youtube video on it as
well
I really really appreciate the support
and the review and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed my book thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of inspector
or espresso give me
I think you've got to find what makes
you tick hmm and I think greatness comes
from when you marry your passion with
your job because I don't really think I
have a job I just I love what I do and I
always say that to kids I've talked to a
lot of kids for a university and say how
do I make a lot of money
I said forgets a lot of money part find
something you're going to be great at
and let the money follow you so what
what is it about people who find their
passion who work hard and never make a
dime well they make a few dimes but not
enough they never get there you know
Fanny it's interesting because we have
this conversation all the time I live in
a very affluent area and I have these
quarterly dinners or used to with my
neighbors so at one point I had 20 guys
they were all worth hundreds of millions
of dollars and we asked that same
question can you always be successful
even if you love what you do and all the
other stuff and the reality is as my dad
said if you work hard right you will
never be poor in life but just because
you work hard doesn't mean you'll be
rich sometimes you need to get lucky but
but the reality is that the harder you
work it true the luckier you get so I
don't really remember the exact day or
anything but when I was in college is
when I started thinking about wanting to
be an entrepreneur someday so it was I
was not the kid with the lemonade stand
you know I didn't I wasn't one of these
kids who was always trying to race me I
always want to be a scientist when I was
little but I'd also always loved
computers I like I was lucky because of
my age this is unusual to have access to
a mainframe computer from my elementary
school when I was in fourth grade and
quickly learned that there was a
pre-programmed Star Trek game on that
computer and then I never did anything
except play Star Trek with the computer
so I know how formative that was
certainly led it certainly helped my
Star Trek knowledge considerably and and
but I've always loved computers
somewhere in college I started watching
some of the people who are like setting
up you know college pizza delivery
services and you know the kind of the
core entrepreneurs and thinking you know
this looks like a really fun thing to do
- I mean I really really enjoy what I do
I really do and I think you know a
number of you probably are interested in
consulting I think my only advice and I
hope that I'm a few years older the news
I have the right to give you a little
bit of advice but my only advice is pick
something that you will thoroughly enjoy
whatever that may be and I think if you
do that you know you will transfer the
first individuals question they'll
probably survive in it and potentially
maybe you'll thrive in it I mean I
usually don't say this but you know if
I'd if I wasn't paid a lot of money I
would still do what I what I what I what
I do I hope you know some of our
managing partners don't see this program
because my units may get cut but I would
still do I would still do what what I do
you know I'm surprised on a yearly basis
as to what kind of money I make I mean I
just am absolutely surprised I would do
it for a tenth of what I make so you
know just find something that you really
enjoy and I think you'll try